like this has
devastated me and i'm just one person it
is globally the first
major car show since the outbreak i
basically started making clothes because
i couldn't find the clothes that i
wanted to wear welcome to your world by
bloomberg quick take i'm jennifer in new
york
and i'm kurumi in tokyo
the copen 19 pandemic is a medical
crisis but it's also been an
economic one affecting millions who have
found themselves in uneasy financial
situations
that financial unease has come to a head
here in new york where an eviction
moratorium has expired
leaving many without a clear future
i am currently being harassed and
getting ready to be
evicted doing the pandemic now
where are you gonna go who's gonna go i
[Music]
it just shows the utter lack of care for
the people of this country
that aren't the ultra wealthy like this
has devastated me
and i'm just one person
[Music]
the cdc has recently issued
what they call an eviction moratorium
nationwide until the end of december of
this year
in order to be eligible for this
eviction moratorium
tenants need to submit to their
landlords a declaration
as specified by the cdc including a
number of statements
[Music]
we're looking at potentially hundreds of
thousands of
tenants who will be student eviction
proceedings and facing eviction
i've been fighting my landlord with this
eviction situation
since 2019 they're trying to say that i
don't own
the place i'm staying they had me down
as a squatter
trying to harass me and force me out
i've been trying to get my landlord to
do repairs
in the apartment this is the kitchen
area
if you go inside and look at the sink
that's pretty bad
i i cannot wash
properly without that basin that's it
that's
my kitchen sink in there that's my
bathroom sink your wash up
i can't use my shower for fear that that
would
overflow moratoriums are supposed to
protect you
they don't people who are
african-american
hispanic or being forced out
i listen to all this uh black lives
matter situation
and i say to myself
my life matters as a senior
because of this now federal moratorium
we are definitely seeing an
uptick in incidents of landlord
harassment
landlords are in a number of cases that
that i'm aware of
moving themselves or sometimes people
off the street into
apartments with their existing tenants
so as to harass them and intimidate them
and
encourage them to voluntarily leave the
apartment
parallel
[Music]
these are the sorts of tactics that a
lot of landlords are resorting to
when they effectively can't move forward
with legal eviction proceedings
i had brain surgery on june 16th
and when i got home everything was just
destroyed
[Music]
constitutes of an illegal lockout is
changing the locks on a building
throwing tenants possessions out or
using verbal or
physical intimidation or harassment
techniques to
make people feel unsafe and basically
implied that they have no other option
but to leave and all three happen to us
yeah yeah
our landlord breaks into our house for
the first time
i sent my landlords an email detailing
everything that i was going through
health-wise
and was like your behavior has made this
house
unsafe and you could quite literally
kill me with your
actions when you have
police come and the police say like yeah
they can do that then they're
now now these corrupt landlords they're
in power right
because they have the backing of the
system
so what are we left with nothing
except community and the hopes of
solidarity
after that break-in i immediately was
like this is not a safe space
[Music]
i have actually never ever even paid my
rent late
ever once in my life i'm just another
person like many people throughout this
country that has been negatively
affected by this pandemic who's lost
work
where the systems that failed me like i
think the eviction moratorium obviously
didn't help us
because here we are so
these these piecemail efforts by new
york state and by the federal government
to kick the can down the road and delay
evictions here and delay evictions there
they aren't solving the fundamental
problem which is these
billions and billions of dollars of
unpaid rent that has accumulated
the tenants of new york state are
continuing to advocate for rent
cancellation
with respect to the rents that have come
due since the pandemic began
here in this community are demanding a
rent cancellation
we are demanding a moratorium that is
real for our communities
not just a paws on rep but we need a
moratorium on rent we need to cancel
rent
if tenants were not able to pay this
debt
a couple of months ago how do we expect
them to continue
to pay accrued debt moving forward
we're permanently saddling people with
death that they'll never be able to pay
to the question what about the landlords
there's no question that this
coveted pandemic has been hard on
everybody and just like tenants
everywhere are suffering
so too are some landlords especially
small landlords
suffering as well while canceling rent
for tenants
the this movement also proposes that
small landlords and financial need
also be given financial support from the
state so they can stay afloat
it's like if you really want to give
people the opportunity
to make their way out of this pandemic
don't risk their life
and their safety by then pushing them
out on the street
unless new york state does something to
address the rent itself to cancel it
uh we're going to see a massive tidal
wave of evictions whenever these
moratoriums stop being issued whether
that's in
october or december or whenever it
really ends
[Music]
parents all over the world are feeling
the stress of juggling both work and
caring for their kids
we talked to one mom in mexico who
shared her struggles of trying to do her
job
while helping three kids with remote
learning
[Music]
process
[Music]
is
tenga
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
share book student
student book
[Music]
initially a grand conflict
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
it's been called china's silicon valley
shenzhen is celebrating its 40th
anniversary
as a special economic zone this year
bloomberg news's alan wan takes us on a
tour of the world technology hub
[Music]
i'm here in shenzhen actually on a
government organized tour to commemorate
the um
the 40th anniversary of the opening of
shenzhen special economic zones
my first stop is here at the ma wan port
it's basically a traditional seaport but
they're transforming it into what's
called a smart port
and they're doing that by deploying a
huawei's 5g
as well as using a 10 cents cloud
computing
one thing i notice around here is that
not a lot of people just because
everything is automated
they're also using great technology
as well as beta which is the chinese
equivalent of gps
i'm over here in shanghai which is a
area in shenzhen that the government is
developing in order to better integrate
the city and hong kong zhuhai it's all
part of plans for the greater bay area
it's sort of like imagine wall street
and san francisco's famous fisherman's
wharf
they're trying to lure a lot of you know
companies and talent
to come to this area by offering a lot
of tax incentives
one way of looking at ten high is it's
chinese big bet
that this is going to be the new model
driving
the country going forward
i'm in front of 10 cent headquarters the
most
interesting thing about tencent was
actually it's exhibition hall
it's been like a scientific technology
museum but with sort of a
disneyland type interactive elements
this is the last stop from a whirlwind
tour
second tallest building in china
this is the view of the ping on building
from the 116th floor
overlooking shenzhen
[Music]
the beijing car show has made a return
in the age of covet 19
and while there may be more face masks
than usual at this year's show
much of it looks to be business as usual
this is the opening day of the china
auto show
[Music]
it is globally the first major car show
since the outbreak
of the kovid 19 pandemic as you can see
it's very busy and that
is testament to some extent to china's
ability to
control the virus but also to the
economic recovery that we've seen here
even if it is
some would argue divergent between the
wealthy cities
and the countryside what we're seeing
here when we speak to executives from
the likes of
porsche or aston martin over here is
that they see sales
rebounding porsche says they're going to
have probably
a record year in 2020 which is
incredible
if you consider the impacts of the virus
on the economy here aston martin says
they will probably match 2019
sales another big topic
at the auto show this year is electric
vehicles and a name of course that hangs
over all of this
is elon musk of tesla he has set himself
a target potentially of trying to
produce as many as a million vehicles
here in
china he's also talked about the 25 000
tesla
at some point that is a big part of the
conversation here you've got domestic
startups
like x-pung which recently listed in the
us you've got
neo also listed in the us they are all
trying to position themselves
to try and snap at the heels of elon
musk and tesla
here in china as that demand for
electric vehicles starts to pick up
we've seen now
two straight months of improving sales
in
china the question is whether that will
be sustained whether china can keep the
virus at bay and whether consumers here
continue to have deep enough pockets to
spend on big ticket items
like cars as the economy recovers but at
a pretty modest pace
after six months of a fear and
in a way for for many industries of
despair it's uh it's good to start again
as you see there's much less people than
they're used to
but it's better than nothing i think
and it's always nice to gather in full
safety as you see
and and hopefully uh everybody will
will act accordingly so i think it's a
good
yes symbol of renewal
[Music]
telfar clement has made a name for
himself using his
own name as a brand for an unorthodox
collection
of unisex clothes and bags here's how he
says
he's found mainstream success on his own
terms
if it's important to me and i'm looking
all over the world
to try to find this thing online
wherever and it doesn't exist it's like
i need to make
it wasn't like i had like a role model
or like a road to follow
you know like everything i kind of had
to figure out i basically started making
clothes because
i couldn't find the clothes that i
wanted to wear
i wanted to make affordable art wearable
[Music]
art
the reason why people didn't buy your
collection because they didn't know
where to put it
you know in the men's or the women's
section like in the beginning we were
trying to break
into fashion and then immediately trying
to break out of fashion
it's like you saw the worst side of
every
possible part of the industry every part
and that's what led us down all of these
paths
you know that's why we knew that we had
to cultivate a customer that was
separate from fashion
we couldn't depend on their magazines we
couldn't depend on
any of the apparatus that was there and
we had to build this
like you know organically what we did
was i think best described as like
social practice because if you're
trading everything for
money like you don't even have time to
live in the time that we're living in is
the thing that we're producing
there's a whole reason for having a
business can materialize
is our autonomy over our own space and
time and to be able to share that with
other people
we just had to change the space
of what we were existing in i feel like
i'm
acting out on those emotions now and
just like actually running my business
the way how i would want it to be run
you know in conducting this story the
way how i
see it happening not like how a movie
played it out
you know because there's no reference of
me so much of the company is actually
just
about allowing telford to be how he is
and not
try to do some other thing including
having to tell his story
including the ability to change the
story
i can't compare it to what this person
did or how this person did it
it's like everything's new and you're
not that person
so i'm trying to just get more into the
person that i actually am
you know
[Music]
we're in a world where there is such
thing as fashion and such thing as
luxury products
that's not what we're about you know
that's the category that precedes us
you know it's not even in my vibe to
aspire to be luxurious creating for
myself i'm creating for them
and for the world that we want to see
you know
and live in when i say the bag it's a
bag
i could see everybody having this bag
and it's not
based on like how much money you have
like where you hang out at night
where you live it's more interesting
when you see everybody
in something rather than a few people
it's like this kind of like
icu kind of thing it's like you have
that bag you have those shoes
you have those jeans it's like you're
into the same things that maybe i'm into
or completely not
but you look good or you don't look good
[Music]
that's our show for this week thanks as
always for watching and remember to
follow bloomberg quick take on twitter
facebook
instagram and youtube and for a daily
recap of the day's top stories visit
quicktake.video
thanks for watching